what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves a trailer
for The Beetle that is blue John how are
you I am unbelievably excited oh you're
making me feel a boost of golden Smiles
ladies and gentlemen leave a like are
you gonna watch this DC movie in the
theaters I hope you do Jaime Reyes
coming in at ya Let's see what's going
on today
[Music]
excuse me Mr Reyes
you finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
I think right now you always land on
your feet bro you're hymen Corgi this
record I think so they don't get out
much where's Ted
I like the colors games but do not open
it you went in to get a shot Big Valley
Burger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked what the hell is this
speed up Works how did you get it to do
that I think he likes me whoa
freaking George Lucas
whoa
oh wow
yes Megan horrific
that looks painful
[Music]
painful
scare of sight guys
oh
it looks great re-entry systems ready
that sounds like Karen is saying what
you want
to touch with the hand of the water
it's called this character it's some
kind of world destroying weapons it's
designed to protect its host do you see
in the buses sometimes it does what you
want and sometimes it does it I like the
Scarab side yeah it's like I I think I
cut a bus in half
whoa Matrix
it belongs to me
hello you feel for your family
makes you weak
awesome awesome cheats to actions the
universe is a sensual gift family is
involved that's what you're going to do
with it
whatever you can imagine
let's do this all right
oh I love the Weaponry giant anime Sword
I love the Weaponry yes
sweets
whoa It's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist oh damn excited to talk about it
let's talk about it I mean yeah look
like full disclosure I'm not exactly
like a Blue Beetle expert by any stretch
and if you're one of McCoy genre is he's
hosting some big panels at Megacon right
now the weekend of a bunch of trailers
that are coming out I'm familiar with
bloop I've played the Injustice games
I've seen another animated medium
crossovers I've read some comics where
Blue Beetle does appear and I think you
just watched the DC animated movie
versus Teen Titans he squares off with
Damien Wayne so I loved seeing all the
powers fully realized here from uh I
think the terminology is like
technomorphy when it comes to the
Weaponry the manipulation abilities the
Scarab sighting the flight obviously a
lot of this movie has this family Vibe I
have three movies that came to mind when
watching let's see if they're the same
spot of Iron Man Shazam the first one
and Venom oh exactly three of those
movies feel like they're they're at play
here sure and it's cool that Blue Beetle
is getting this opportunity to shine
because I believe that Jaime Reyes he
came into the fold around the new 52 era
because he's like the third Blue Beetle
like the mainly popular one but prior to
Jaime Reyes was Ted cord and I I need to
rewind this did that say chord on the
building because I heard the rumor being
that Susan Sarandon's character is kod
yeah is the sister of Ted cord perhaps
we'll get a tet Court cameo in here
because Ted cord was the Blue Beetle
then eventually it was Jaime Reyes so
yeah I imagine that it'll somehow link
to Ted Court ultimately we got Booster
Gold who's gonna be having his own DC
animated property in the DCU so I feel
like Blue Beetle is here to stay around
because Blue Beetle and Booster Gold a
big part of what boosted the popularity
of Blue Beetle was the combination of
the two of them but how do you pronounce
his name
my God I feel so bad for never getting
it they're all good I can't just always
call him Miguel from Cobra the casting
director was like get me Miguel he's the
perfect character he is the perfect guy
to be playing this because yeah it has
like the family Dynamics a Scarab I
don't know if they're gonna go full out
here with how much communication
abilities the Scarab does have you know
being able to have like full-on
conversations with him but I think
there's like some humor to generate from
there I think it might be more along the
lines of like Spider-Man homecoming yeah
yeah totally I'm curious to see how they
play that because it didn't feel quite
as much like a living alien entity in
this portrayal as it does like an
advanced AI that powers the suit so I'm
curious to see how the lore kind of
accounts for that but yeah I mean how
much uh intelligence does the suit
actually have what what availability it
seems like they can communicate pretty
well she's like upset assessing his
weapon choices and all that stuff
doesn't seem like there'll be too much
of a barrier there necessary necessarily
but even so I mean I think it would be
fun to watch him have to learn the suit
but especially for just like Charming
the world and giving everybody their a
lot of people is going to be the first
they've heard of Blue Beetle as a
character at all simplifying that a
little bit is probably a good thing for
the general audience and it's not like
the main point but yeah like this just
looks so much fun and those are the
exact kind of movies that came to mind a
little bit of upgrade too when he's
actually going through like the first
suit transformation which was compared
to Venom definitely exactly he's pretty
much yeah so you got better this looks
really fun and colorful and bouncy and
and something that I could see on a
streaming scenario but I'm glad that
they boosted this to the theatrical
because this again looks like something
that can have that level of fun that
they were looking for in something like
a Shazam but that also seems like it's
got some potential to be like a semi at
least not like gritty-gritty but like a
bit of an effect in Coming of Age story
too because oh a thousand percent yeah
and like the transformation as I
understand it is supposed to be a bit
painful and it certainly looks like it
is here and so just like that
relationship I think will be really
fascinating to see and two with this
being placed after flash like doing a
little bit of reading on like the
history of the character in general like
this wasn't even always a DC character
and Blue Beetle was co-opted into DC I
think after like Crisis it was around
the time of I think Peacemaker was part
of the same company prior I think this
coming right after the flash will
actually kind of probably bode well for
his inclusion uh in the future and then
having Damien Wayne in the mix as well I
think I'll just make for some really fun
potential Teen Titans stuff I love the
way the weapons are realized that you
said anime during the reaction and it
does have that anime Flair too sure yeah
like it looks breathtaking yeah it's
beautiful to look at it's beautiful to
behold yeah and that's the thing is like
this could easily look like big bad
Beetleborgs and it doesn't it looks like
it has that fun and I like that they
kept the heads up display as something
that looks a little more cartoon and a
little more of the natural world I guess
it's a little more organic feeling and I
think that's cool but like his just the
suit and the look of the effects and
everything is like Top Notch so I'm I
don't know what kind of influx of money
they got for this but it seems to
certainly be paying off well I love the
choice of the cinematography here
because I'm a filmmaking level you do
get this great color palette of a lot of
purple and blue Shades throughout this
entire aesthetic yeah and you got George
Lopez you got George Lopez and you got
the girl from Hocus Pocus who oh and big
belly burger that is a a reoccurring
restaurant within I don't know if it's
been in the I think it was in the
arrowverse at one point it's like a
reoccurring fast food restaurant in the
in the DC world I feel like it's been
some of the animated stuff ever yeah it
must have been uh but yeah to see it in
live action I think is really fun oh
sure uh but yeah no I I thought this
trailer was a lot of fun really exciting
I hope this movie is a hit because I
like Blue Beetle to carry on into the DC
Universe especially to interact with the
members in the play the new Booster Gold
but yeah guys thank you so much for
being here leave a like what did you
think about this trailer leave your
thoughts down below uh be sure to
subscribe click that Bell hey let's send
this with a pink
Ricardo Martinez we've got ourselves a
Latin superhero and we got ourselves a
Latino to shout out Ricardo you sexy
sexy beast you I would love for the
Scarab to attach itself to your body so
that way you can come fly over here and
pay us a visit that would be the main
thing we would just want to take
advantage of your powers and we can go
traveling and stuff and I'd have you
beat up my arch nemesis for me blind
wave they're in Ohio fly us over to Ohio
get Eric yeah yeah it's great
no man it's great to be having you at
our patreon page and I'm curious to know
how you feel man we don't do we is there
is this the first like
Latin superhero Latino I keep saying
Latin Latino front and center I I
believe it is or at least in a way where
it's like you know overtly part of the
character's personality I mean we've had
you know the The Ghost Writer uh uh
Robbie Reyes but uh yeah you know not in
a full you know Fleet of a cinematic
Motion Picture well it's time to take
that pride in my friend because you've
earned it for being a super sexy reject
for so long love you buddy hope you're
having a great day
[Music]